là les caddies et kelly est célibataire
est ma morale dont vous avez la très
belle main ouais moi c'est pas parce que
je touche plus que j'adore les dents il
a un très beau sourire ouais c'est pas
parce qu'elles touchent peu car garder
ma vitesse et ma préférée elle en
traitement d'eau douce quoi ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
vva
aussi tout envie de danser avec eux et
isabelle non problèmes psy
[Applaudissements]
plus
et métiers
[Applaudissements]
enfin
il quittera quittait toile au bowling
mille un très très beau village un très
très beau village et c'est vrai pourquoi
juste à la fin se bat encore vous pouvez
encore le mais la jambe contraire moi de
leurs mots qui ne peut plus rien levée
[Applaudissements]